weapons of terror fired to the sound of
triumphant music in a video released by
russian-backed separatists claiming
these thermobaric explosives known as
vacuum bombs were fired near mario pole
sky news has been unable to verify this
footage but what we can say with
certainty is they inflict horrific
impact
sucking the air out of people's lungs
as they pull in oxygen to generate an
explosion
many felt it was a matter of time before
these bombs were used in ukraine
the destroyed city of mariopol a clear
example russia appears to have no
boundaries
an estimated 300 000 people remain
trapped here subjected to nightly
bombing
anastasia managed to escape with 20
minutes warning
she fled for her life but hasn't heard
from her relatives in the three days
since when they started
bombing us from
airplanes it was already impossible to
stay we were hiding just in our
apartment we did not have any
shelter close to us or something like
this now i'm i am thinking about food
but that we still have left in my
apartment and i'm thinking that
oh my god it could be
helpful for my neighbors maybe we could
give that food to someone we were just
we did not have time we just have
something like 20 minutes to park i only
took my laptop and shoes with me that's
that's it
so
i was crying about
you know that maybe it would help
someone the city has been without power
water and food supplies for days
anastasia shared this video with sky
news showing the lengths she had to go
to just for drinking water
queuing at the well closest to her
apartment where she'd remained in hiding
after this theater was bombed many
fierce shelters have become targets
four days on more than a thousand
civilians are thought to remain trapped
in its basement
now an art school has been hit too
sheltering 400 people including children
and the elderly
rescuers unable to reach them due to
russian forces fighting street to street
president zielenski has described these
as war crimes that will go down in
history
and emphasizing his jewish faith the
ukrainian leader has appealed to the
israeli parliament to break their
neutral stance over this war
this is a full-scale war aimed to
destroy our nation our children our
families our state our towns cities
communities culture
everything
they even use the terms that we use
during the second world war
these are the pictures moscow wants its
people to see on state media ukrainian
refugees rescued from mariopol and
brought to russian territory
but ukrainian officials claim thousands
of citizens have been removed from
shelters against their will
their passports taken and then relocated
in remote locations in russia
russia has committed nearly all possible
war crimes
which the humanity has seen over the
second world war russians have tried to
legitimize the evocation of ukrainian
people to russia and belarus through
international organization where they
were blocked and it has been um
recognized and absolutely a nonsense to
evocate people to the territory of the
country who has started the aggression
on ukrainian territory so now they do it
forcefully
the fate of civilians in the south is of
growing concern
tanks now also on the streets of badansk
in russia's destructive path to build a
land bridge from russia to crimea
as the agony deepens for this country
sally lockwood sky news in western
ukraine